[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
elisabeth bornes bonjour madame la
ministre son ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
patrice millions de ouest france jean
patrice bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous on commence bien sûr par cette
crise sanitaire les mesures annoncées
par emmanuel macron mercredi détaillé
par jean castex hier dont un couvre-feu
qui entrera en vigueur dans quelques
heures et demain soir à 21h en ile de
france et dans huit métropoles
il faudrait être chez soi on a compris
que le gouvernement voulait frapper fort
pour lutter contre cette deuxième vague
est ce que c'est assez fort pour vous
écoutez je pense que c'était important
effectivement alors qu'on voit que le
nombre de nouveaux cas chaque jour
augmente et on était à plus de trente
mille cas hier que le nombre de patients
en réanimation a dépassé dès 1500 il
faut absolument casser cette dynamique
et on le sait il ya beaucoup de domaines
dans lequel il ya des protocoles
sanitaires très strictes qui ont été mis
en place c'est le cas notamment dans les
entreprises
c'est le cas aussi les cinémas les
théâtres et il ya effectivement la
partie de la sphère privée je dirais
quand on se retrouve avec sa famille
avec ses amis on sait que c'est là que
se passe des contaminations et il
fallait prendre des mesures je vous dis
pour casser la dynamique de l'épidémie
et c'est bien le sens de ce qu'on 21h
c'est pas trop tard 21h pourquoi ne pas
l'avoir pris plus tôt pour casser plus
la dynamique de cette épidémie
je pense qu'à aussi à prendre en compte
enfin le rythme de vie sains des
métropoles dans lesquelles ces couvre
feu vont s'appliquer où on a peut-être
une vie un peu décalé par rapport au
reste du territoire on rentre chez soi
voilà donc on a essayé de trouver la
bonne mesure pour être efficace et en
même temps tenir compte des modes de vie
dans ces grandes métropoles alors ce
couvre-feu va s'appliquer notamment à
paris une ville qui a été déjà
lourdement touché pour les restaurateurs
les hôteliers
avec une chute une diminution du nombre
de touristes
alors vous vous prenez un certain nombre
de mesures prolongement prolong de dd
ali mais est-ce que ça va être suffisant
parce qu'il ya une vraie inquiétude dans
ce secteur-là savez avec bruno le maire
on échange vraiment très régulièrement
avec les représentants de ces secteurs
qui sont effectivement touché le secteur
du tourisme au sens large je dirais y
compris l'hôtellerie restauration
on est à leurs côtés moi je suis
parfaitement consciente du choc que ça a
été ils sont un peu sidérée de ce qui
leur arrive vraiment l'engagement du
gouvernement c'est qu'on va mettre le
paquet pour les soutenir encore plus
qu'avant
c'est vrai sur l'activité partielle
savait qu'on prend en charge 100 % de
l'activité partielle donc zéro reste à
charge pour les entreprises
dans le même temps on renforce le fonds
de solidarité qui a été porté à dix
mille euros par mois dans ce secteur
comme vous l'avez dit en prolonge on
allonge les prêts garantis par l'état il
ya des annulations de charges sociales
on sait qu'il ya encore des points qui
sont pas satisfaisants ils nous le
disent sur les loyers sur les congés
payés et on va continuer à travailler on
les reverra avec bruno le maire dès le
début de la semaine prochaine ça veut
dire que des mesures pourraient être
prises sur ces sujets la semaine
prochaine ça veut dire qu'il faut
effectivement qu'on complète le bouclier
qu'on veut mettre en place pour qu'il
n'y ait aucune défaillance liée à ces
mesures de restriction qu'on est amené à
prendre pour protéger la santé des
français
donc ça veut dire notamment des mesures
sur les loyers vous pourriez prendre en
charge pour elle de juger ayant nommé ce
sujet enfin je vous dis c'est au coeur
des réflexions du ministère de
l'économie pour ma part le secteur nous
soumet le sujet des congés payés qui
s'accumulent qui est comme ils le disent
une sorte de bombe à retardement pour le
secteur et on prend c'est ce qu'a dit
jean castex hier absolument dont on
comprend bien ces points je vous dis il
faut absolument qu'on est la protection
la plus large possible pour ces secteurs
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de défaillances
d'entreprises pas de destructions
d'emplois malgré les mesures qu'on est
amené à prendre effectivement du fait du
couvre-feu
et justement puisque vous parlez de
destructions d'emplois est ce que vous
avez déjà des chiffres sur des
descriptions d'emplois dans ces secteurs
de la restauration et de l'hôtellerie
alors on sait vous savez l'insee indiqué
qu'il y avait eu sept cent mille
destructions d'emplois au cours du
premier semestre
et c'est à peu près un tiers qui
concerne ce secteur du tourisme
donc on est vraiment très attentifs à
leur donner tous les bons dispositif
dans ce secteur et dans tous les
secteurs pour protéger les emplois pour
protéger des salariés et les
indépendants puisque mozilla n'a pas su
faire pour éviter de nouvelles
destructions d'emplois c'est vraiment
l'objectif d'arriver à avoir vraiment
une palette de mesures qui protègent les
entreprises de ce secteur comme les
autres là le chômage partiel est
prolongé jusqu'à la fin de l'année il ya
les prêts garantis par l'état qui ont
été prolongées jusqu'au 30 juin jusqu'à
quand vous allez pouvoir prolonger ces
aides
aussi longtemps que nécessaire très
clairement aussi longtemps que
nécessaire
vous savez je pense que l'on parle du
chômage partiel dont je sais que les
restaurateurs nous le disent leur
objectif c'est d'arriver à travailler
donc moi j'ai pas de doute que la
majorité des restaurateurs va vouloir
rester ouverts pendant la période qui
quittent autorisé donc et pour ceux qui
effectivement des baisses de leurs
activités aussi longtemps que nécessaire
en mettra en place un accompagnement
pour protéger ce secteur et que ça veut
dire que le chômage partiel pourrait
aussi être prolongé jusqu'au 30 juin
effectivement on avisera en fonction de
la situation mais je vous dis on sera
aux côtés des entreprises du secteur et
on sera là pour protéger des emplois
un mot quand même sur le chômage partiel
parce que aucun autre pays n'a pris des
mesures aussi généreuse pour soutenir
effectivement l'emploi pour accompagner
les salariés
maintenant il ya peut-être un problème
de contrôle vous 270000 contrôle sur 4
millions de demandes qui ont été faites
vous aviez chiffrées au mois de
septembre de 125 millions d'euros d'abus
mais est-ce qu'il faut pas renforcé tout
de même c ces contrôles veiller à ce que
ces aides aillent bien effectivement aux
sociétés et aux personnes qui en ont
réellement besoin qu est-ce que qu'est
ce que vous faites pour puisque on voit
que ce dispositif est prolongé
maintenant oui mais vous avez enfin moi
vraiment jeu de façon très très larges
ce dispositif il atteint sa cible
c'est un bouclier massif là encore pour
protéger des emplois pour protéger les
entreprises et on sait qu'au plus fort
de la crise on est
près de 9 millions de salariés dont la
rémunération a été assuré par l'état
heureusement l'activité économique
repart on a parlé des secteurs qui vont
mal heureusement il ya des secteurs qui
vont bien et dont l'activité repart je
pense par exemple au bâtiment et aux
travaux publics met donc sur tous ces
secteurs
il faut continuer à les protéger on fait
des contrôles ont fait des contrôles a
priori on vous l'avait dit 220000
contrôle a priori 50000 qu'on se
contrôle à postériori pendant l'été
finalement un nombre limité de cas qui
sont plutôt des fraudes et des
escroqueries
donc ce ne sont pas les entreprises qui
fraudent c'est souvent des gens qui par
exemple usurpé des identités
on travaille avec les équipes du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
pour vraiment traquer ces fraudeurs et
ces escrocs je vais instruments pour ça
aujourd hui je pense qu'aujourd'hui vous
savez on s'est mis en relation
effectivement avec les équipes de livier
du soft pour croiser les fichiers et
pour mobiliser toutes les outils qu'on
peut avoir pour identifier les escrocs
et les fraudeurs alors vraiment je pense
qu'on a enfin il faut aussi avoir en
tête qu on avait l'objectif au début de
la crise d'être très réactif et donc de
donner ces aides en 48 heures là les
derniers des textes qui s'applique
maintenant donne un peu plus de temps
pour instruire les dossiers de demande
d'activité partielle parce qu'on est
maintenant plus rodés et on voit bien
les secteurs sont bien identifiés et
donc du coup ça nous donne aussi plus de
temps pour traquer les fraudeurs en
amont on va parler du protocole
sanitaire notamment dans les entreprises
selon santé public français dans les
entreprises que se trouve le plus grand
nombre de foyers de contamination
non non non non je peux pas laisser dire
ça non ce sont les chiffres
alors regardez on va on va vous on va
vous les affiches et 25 % des foyers de
contamination selon selon santé publique
francs se trouvent aujourd'hui dans des
entreprises publiques ou privées est ce
qu'à un risque aujourd'hui alors ce que
nous dit santé publique france c'est que
les clusters qui sont les quelques cas
finalement de propagation de l'épidémie
qu'on suit évidemment on les suit dans
des milieux on s'est tracée mais on sait
que ces clusters c'est moins de 10% des
cas de co vide
donc faut pas non plus se tromper là on
met ses 25 % des clusters identifié
aujourd'hui enfin des foyers de
contamination il a ratifié aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui deux cents 200 cluster
actifs en entreprise il y à plus de deux
millions d'entreprises en france
donc moi je peux vous le dire il ya un
protocole sanitaires très strictes qui
s'applique depuis le 1er septembre avec
le port du masque obligatoire dès que
vous êtes dans des espaces de travail
clos et partager et se protège de ce
protocole
il est efficace les entreprises qui le
met en oeuvre
il n'ya pas de chaîne de contamination
qui savait qu'on en a un certain nombre
et moi j'en ai visité qu'il avait mis en
pl qui avait mis en place ces règles dès
le début de la crise il n'ya pas de
chaîne de contamination quand on
respecte tous les gestes barrière savela
respect de la distance nettoyage des
surfaces 20 mars pour son nom mais je
vous dise et les quelques fins
l'essentiel de la contamination se passe
dans la sphère privée et on ne va pas
tracer chez les gens donc on ne on ne
les identifie pas donc il faut pas se
tromper c'est vraiment une toute petite
partie des cas on sait que c'est dans
des secteurs particuliers avec lesquels
on travaille ça va c'est quand il ya des
hébergements collectifs par exemple on
sait que les métiers du froid dans
lequel il ya des conditions
particulières on a eu des cas en
abattoir on a du coup travailler avec le
secteur pour renforcer les règles et ce
sont des situations très particulières
on les identifie c'est bien pour ça
qu'on continue à travailler avec santé
publique france pour les identifier et
on renforce les mesures sur ses
activités particulières mais également
je le dis vraiment très clairement ce
protocole en entreprise
il est très efficace il n'ya pas de
chaîne de contamination si vous
appliquez tous ces gestes barrières il
est par ailleurs très bien appliqué il
ya eu plus de cinquante mille
interventions de l'inspection du travail
depuis le déconfinement en entreprise
ait eu un peu plus de 300 mises en
demeures
donc ça veut dire que les entreprises
les chefs d'entreprise sont conscients
de leurs responsabilités
les partenaires sociaux sont aussi là
pour rappeler les règles et attirer
l'attention de leur employeur si ça
n'était pas le cas donc ce protocole
il est à la fois efficace et très bien
appliqué ce protocole sanitaire vous
allez le renforcer le modifier compte
tenu de la recrudescence de l'épidémie
alors ce protocole il va
évoluer sur deux points notamment sur le
télétravail
donc moi je le redis on peut aller au
travail en sécurité mais c'est important
dans le contexte que l'on connaît de
réduire les interactions sociales que ce
soit au sein de l'entreprise mais aussi
aux abords de l'entreprise dans les
déplacements domicile travail
donc on va demander aux entreprises en
particulier dans les zones qui font
l'objet d'un couvre-feu de définir un
nombre minimal de jours par semaine en
télétravail pour les postes qui le
permette qui on va aussi demander aux
entreprises d'étaler les horaires
d'arrivée et de départ pour éviter
l'affluence mais ça le crâne sur la base
du volontariat n'y aura pas d'obligation
d'un nombre minimum de jours alors on
demande aux entreprises d'en débattre
dans l'entreprise dans le dialogue
social je pense que c'est important
parce que vous savez une règle nationale
qui serait plaqué sur des activités
quelles que soient la taille quel que
soit le secteur d'activité serait
inadapté moi j'ai réuni les partenaires
sociaux hier est unanimement que ce soit
les organisations patronales ou
représentant les salariés sont d'accord
sur le fait que c'est dans le dialogue
social au sein de l'entreprise qu'on va
trouver des bonnes raisons du mal à se
mettre d'accord sur le télétravail les
partenaires sont par ailleurs engagés et
accepter collectivement d'engager une
négociation en vue d'un accord qui
donnera des repères pour les futurs
accords d'entreprise et de branches
alors il y aura une obligation quand
même date d'un accord avec les
partenaires sociaux dans les entreprises
ou où il ya une chef d'entreprise pour
arroser
non mais c'est une obligation de
discuter d'un nombre minimum de jours de
télétravail pour les postes qui de
permettent je crois qu'il faut aussi
avoir en tête que ça fait plusieurs
semaines maintenant qu'on passe le
message de l'importance du télétravail
en tout cas de l'intérêt du télétravail
ces messages ils sont entendus on a fait
une enquête mon ministère a fait une
enquête en début de semaine qui montrait
que plus de la moitié des salariés nous
disent que dans leurs entreprises
l'employeur recommande le télétravail
donc je ce nombre de salariés en
télétravail a beaucoup augmenté
c'est ce qui explique par exemple qu en
ile de france la fréquentation des
transports en commun est inférieur de
40% à ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle était en
donc je pense que les mentalités ont
changé je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
employeurs ont bien compris l'intérêt du
télétravail par contre là encore tous
les partenaires sociaux unanimement nous
disent qu'il faut aussi trouver un
équilibre entre l'intérêt du télétravail
pour réduire les interactions sociales
pour limiter aussi la fatigue des
salariés dans les déplacements
mais en même temps il ya un enjeu
important qu'il faut avoir en tête de
garder les collectifs de travail
et puis de faire attention aussi aux
risques psychologiques liés à
l'isolément des salariés
c'est pour ça qu'il faut trouver cet
équilibre dans le dialogue social au
sein de l'entreprise alors on parle de
l'entreprise mais comment ça va se
passer dans la fonction publique vous
avez dit que l'état employeur allait
faire des efforts pour la fonction
publique d'état comment ça va se passer
pour la fonction publique territoriale
est ce que vous avez des discussions
avec les collectivités alors dans la
fonction publique d'état vous avez vu
qu'on s'applique à nous même ce qu'on
préconise pour les entreprises puisque
on a dit qu'on va mettre en place deux à
trois jours de télétravail pour tous les
postes qui pour lesquels c'est possible
et moi j'invite les employeurs de la
fonction publique territoriale
ah voilà à rechercher la règle adapté là
aussi il ya des métiers qui sont très
différents il ya des métiers qui sont
pas télétravail à moi je pense à ceux
qui par exemple pour l'entretien des
routes dans les départements ou dans les
communes met donc c'est vraiment et la
xai dans les services publics ça va en
pâtir
l'accueil non mais vraiment je pense que
ce que ce qu'on souhaite c'est télé
travailler pour les postes pour lesquels
c'est possible on va pas réduire
l'accueil dans les services publics va
pas arrêter l'entretien des routes ou
des espaces verts dans les collectivités
donc c'est pour ça que c'est chaque
employeur qui doit avoir ce dialogue
social pour trouver les bonnes règles en
tenant compte de la nature des postes de
travail
alors vous insisté sur l'importance du
dialogue social il y aura justement donc
une conférence sociale
le 26 octobre présidé par le premier
ministre qu'est ce que vous en attendez
concrètement écoutez je pense que cette
conférence de dialogue social c'est la
deuxième et la première s'était tenue
très peu de jours après la nomination de
jean castex et après la mise en place du
gouvernement
cette conférence sociale c'est vraiment
la marque du fait de l'importance que le
premier ministre et moi-même accordons
au dialogue social
on est dans une période totalement
inédite
on doit trouver des solutions ensemble
et le dialogue social c'est une des
voies pour trouver des solutions pour
être le plus efficace et notamment un
des sujets sur lesquels on parle
beaucoup avec les partenaires sociaux
aujourd'hui c'est le plan de relance
c'est comment on sauve le maximum
d'emplois dont très clairement ces
sujets seront au coeur de la conférence
sociale y compris germé à la date du 26
octobre qui est à ce stade confirmé à la
date du 26 octobre vous avez vu que l'on
s'est adjugé aussi en fonction de
l'actualité
mais y compris vous savez un enjeu très
important dont on parle avec les
partenaires sociaux qui est la façon
dont on continue à protéger les salariés
le maximum d'emplois dans les
entreprises par exemple avec l'activité
partielle de longue durée sur lequel on
pourra revenir qu est un dispositif qui
marche très bien mais aussi comment on
accompagne les reconversions pour les
salariés qui sont dans des secteurs qui
rencontrent des difficultés alors même
qu'il ya aussi des secteurs qui vont
bien ou même très bien et qui recrutent
et donc c'est vraiment ce type de sujets
qui sont au coeur des échanges qu'on a
actuellement avec les partenaires
sociaux est justement on va en parler
patrice alors un jeune une solution
juste que jusqu'au mois de février il ya
des effets exceptionnels qui sont
accordés pour les jeunes pour l'
embauche de jeunes de moins de 26 ans 1
5 mille 5000 euros pour les entreprises
qui embauchent des jeunes de moins de 26
ans alors est-ce que vous avez des
chiffres déjà les premiers résultats sur
ce ce plan qui a été mis en place
alors ce plan à il montre enfin il
traduit la priorité que le gouvernement
accorde à la jeunesse
on sait que c'est très dur d'être jeune
en 2020 qui a beaucoup d'inquiétude sur
l'avenir sur son avenir en termes de
formation en termes d'entrées sur le
marché du travail et donc dès le mois de
juillet on a voulu présenter ce plan
massif pour accompagner la jeunesse dans
sa formation dans des formations qui
sont qualifiantes qui vont nous
permettre d'avoir des métiers voilà des
métiers durables et puis pour trouver
effectivement des emplois selon les
premiers résultats qu'on a sont positifs
moi je vais pas crier victoire et on
sera évidemment très attentifs dans le
suivi mais on voit que au mois d'août on
a eu plus d'embaucher de jeunes
sur les contrats à durée indéterminée et
les cdd plus de trois mois donc c'est ce
qu'on soutient avec la prime à l
embauche de 4000 euros
on a eu plus dans bausch 9 % de plus en
2020 en août 2020 qu'en 2019
klee représente combien de 180 mille
embauches 480 mille embauches de jeunes
donc ça montre aussi que les entreprises
entendent le message cette espèce de
solidarité qu'on doit avoir vis-à-vis de
notre jeunesse pour lui permettre
d'entrer sur un marché du travail et
puis donc il ya d'autres dispositions
vous l'avez mentionné pour soutenir les
employeurs qui veulent signer des
contrats d'apprentissage ou de
professionnalisation 5000 euros pour un
mineur 8000 euros pour un majeur
donc ça veut dire que finalement pour
l'entreprise ça ne coûte quasiment rien
quand on embauche un apprenti et là
aussi on a vraiment des signaux positifs
on n'a pas encore les chiffres
consolidés
mais alors qu'on nous disait avant l'été
on nous annonçait -20 à -30% sur
l'apprentissage qui aurait été
catastrophique
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya grande
majorité de secteur dans lequel on sera
au niveau voire même au delà de ce qu'on
a eu en 2019 qui était une année
historiquement haute par exemple c'est
le cas dans le bâtiment c'est le cas
dans beaucoup de métiers de l'artisanat
c'est le cas dans les métiers du soin
donc on a effectivement des signaux
positifs dans ce domaine là qui montre
que l'état est mobilisé mais également
les entreprises ont bien entendu le
message de la nécessité d'accompagner
les jeunes dans leur entrée dans la vie
professionnelle
et puis ce plan jeunes il s'intéresse
aussi aux jeunes qui sont plus éloignés
de l'emploi vous savez ces trois cent
mille parcours d'insertion c'est des
garanties jeunes et moi j'aurais dit un
point vraiment qui me tient à coeur
on a veillé à ce que tous les
dispositifs nombreux qu'on met en place
pour accompagner la jeunesse
à chaque fois il ya une rémunération de
l'ordre de 500 euros pour les jeunes
évidemment quand ils sont embauchés
qu'ils ont un contrat d'apprentissage ça
va aller au delà
mais la garantie jeunes c'est une
rémunération de l'ordre de 500 euros on
a revalorisé la rémunération des
stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle
ça n'avait pas été fait depuis des
années et là encore quand on entre dans
une formation professionnelle on a une
rémunération de 7 ans
hier qui est de l'ordre de 500 euros
sans un mot madame la ministre sur
territoire 0 chômeurs de longue durée
le nouveau texte a été voté par le
parlement ce à prolonger
l'expérimentation salle étant même
désormais il ya soixante territoires qui
sont concernés certains voudraient faire
sauter ce verrou de 60 territoire est ce
que vous allez réfléchir
peut-être un mot pour dire que c'était
important je pense qu'on discute de
cette proposition de la de loi
maintenant moi je me réjouis qu'elle est
votée été votée à l'unanimité à
l'assemblée qu'elle ait aussi été adopté
par le sénat
j'espère que la commission mixte
paritaire permettra d'adopter
définitivement ce texte rapidement et
c'est important parce que ça montre la
volonté partagée entre gouvernement et
le parlement de ne laisser personne sur
le bord de la route
donc ça muscle des dispositifs sur
l'insertion par l'activité économique
pour accélérer les embauches parler les
entreprises d'insertion par l'activité
économique
et puis ça vise effectivement à
pérenniser et à étendre une démarche
complémentaire qui est territoire 0
chômeurs de longue durée
on a porté le nombre à 60 mois je me
suis engagé et donc ce sera fait à
adapter la rédaction du texte en lien
avec notamment les rapporteurs de
l'assemblée et du sénat pour qu'on
s'assure qu'on ne laissera aucun
territoire qui seraient prêts sur le
bord de la route là aussi et donc on
aura une soupape pour permettre à ses
intérêts quand audrey pulvar qui est
candidate
presque candidate en tout cas de la
gauche en ile de france dit moi si je
suis élu je souhaite étendre territoire
0 chômeurs de longue durée à toute l'île
de france vous dites c'est une bonne
idée je dis que c'est des dispositifs
complémentaires
on n'est pas dans une phase de
généralisation
on est dans des phases d'expérimentation
il nous a semblé important d'élargir
l'expérimentation est de permettre à
tous les territoires
je rappelle que c'est pas les régions
qui porte ce genre d'expérimentations
peut-être madame pulvar ne sais pas
encore et donc ce sont les collectivités
les départements qui sont en pointe sur
l'insertion et donc moi je souhaite que
tous ceux qui veulent le faire puissent
effectivement rentré dans ses
expérimentations alors l'économie
dernière question will économistes
pierre cahuc dénoncent le coût de ce
dispositif qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
je pense que c'est important qu'on lève
effectivement ces débats etc
en étant dans l'expérimentation qu'on
aura un laboratoire à la bonne taille
qui permettra aux territoires
volontaires d'expérimenter mais il faut
effectivement on n'est pas au stade de
la généralisation mais bien de
l'élargissement et de la poursuite de
l'expérimentation
merci beaucoup merci madame la ministre
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin merci
patrice moyens on regarde la une de
ouest france consacré bien sûr aux
candidats cette crise sanitaire qu'elle
restriction dès samedi c'est la question
à la une de ouest france merci beaucoup